walker bueller on the mound for game
four that's right the same walk revealer
who started game one of the nlds in san
francisco on friday night and the blue
birds coming out for brandon crawford
who has
done a number on these dodgers all year
long and throughout his career
giants of course won the division by one
game over the dodgers they lead the best
of
five series
and toss on the first base and an easy
ground ball to seeger crawford is
retired and an easy inning for walker
bueller anthony diesel funny the 31 year
old right-hander for the giants he was
13-7 with a 3-17 era over 31 starts now
here's trey turner
and now turner into right center that's
going to get down and go to the wall
seeger off to the races around third
they'll bring him home the throw to the
plate and he's in there
and the dodgers strike first
so two down trey turner's still at
second here is justin turner and here's
the stretch the high sack
the pitch on the way swing gonna miss he
struck him out and he powered it by on
the high hard one at 94 miles an hour
up above the belt
but the dodgers jump ahead
one run and two hits one left we go to
the second with posey bryant and wade
coming up against bueller and the giants
are trailing one nothing the giants now
have first and third with one out and
evan longoria coming up two balls and
two strikes to evan longoria
chris bryant lady from third lamont wade
junior from first now the 2-2 from
bueller swung on and missed strike three
slider away
first strike out of the game for bueller
second out of the second mike yostremski
coming up
chipped on on the right side trey turner
half a dozen steps on the outfield grass
and short right
mueller on two and one to the ostremski
and he drills one on
the fly
into the glove of trade turner a little
knuckler and that will end the inning
no runs two hits to left will go to the
bottom of the second dodgers one and the
giant stuffing now chris taylor
and that one's a high drive left field
back on it is wade he's got it at the
track that's going to deliver another
run ballinger tags as well
and the dodgers
have a two to nothing lead
sack flying an rbi for chris taylor and
he just missed a three-run home run
here is walker bueller
two and two the count
again d staff
ready delivers
swing to the miss he struck him out
with a slider over the heart of the
plate runners at first and third
two down
and seeger the lefty coming up the 1-1
pitch on the way swing and there's a fly
ball into right center
over to his left goes yostremski in
front of the right fielder bryant
yaz takes it
dickerson 13 home runs during the
regular year
and with six for 29 as a pinch hitter
three of the six hits home runs
the 02 strikes out swinging
first out of the third that's the second
strike out of the game for bueller
darren ruff
big strong right-handed hitter a 1-2
rough strikeout swinging on a slider and
that ends the inning
one two three
five in a row retired by bueller three
strikeouts in the game
no runs no hits though errors nobody
left after two and a half it's the
dodgers two and the giants nothing ease
has loaded one away for cody bellinger
two and one garcia throws bellinger
bounces it to ruff he's going to come
home he'll get the out there and that's
all they'll get and the giants had to
make sure that they got the out at home
plate
chris taylor who knocked in a run with a
sacrifice flying might have just missed
a home run his first time up all runners
on the move there they go in a swing and
a drive in the left field back on his
way he's got it what a catch lamont wade
over his shoulder crashing up against
the wall
and somehow the dodgers
come away from all of that without a run
that didn't seem possible and a very
nice play by lamont wade
to take away extra bases if he didn't
catch that that was going to be three
runs for la instead we are through three
and it's still just two-nothing dodgers
crawford bounced to short in his first
at-bat on three and two
crawford takes calls strike three that's
the fourth strikeout for bueller
dodgers two to nothing and here's bets
dodgers
have had
traffic all game that ball's driven into
right field bryant turns and runs monkey
bats
two-run blast
four-nothing dodgers
mookie bets goes the other way and the
dodgers take a four to nothing lead a
two-run shot for betts here in the home
half of the fourth dodgers
have a chance to add to their
four-nothing lead with justin turner in
the batter's box here's the 0-1 from
leon turner hits a high fly ball shallow
right toward the line long run for
yostremski on the move he'll get there
and make the catch as a nice play by
mikey
duggar left-handed hitter his first
at-bat
and duggar draws a walk
so two men aboard for the giants now
with one out
and decision time for dave roberts he's
got kelly ready and the manager is on
his way
is he doing the same thing that he did
with max scherzer in the wildcard game
where he took him out after four and a
third innings yes he is
quick call to the pen doesn't even want
to get
allow bueller a chance to talk his way
in he'll get a nice hand
coming back on three days rest he
pitched beautifully and here comes
darren rough and here's the possible
tying run
swinging the ground ball to the right
side over to his left trey turner he's
got it and he'll take the
shore out at first base
throws out rough coming into score is
longoria the other runners also advance
brandon crawford coming up
now the pitch to crawford
ground ball slowly hit the third in
comes turner second hop picks it up
throws him out and the inning is over
for the giants one run two hits two left
and after four and a half it's a dodgers
four as a giants one
chance to bring the infield in
with chris taylor at the plate he is hit
a sacrifice fly and fly down deep to
left the pitch doing
swinging the ground ball right back to
leone he's got
lux hung up
off third runs right toward him then
flips the ball to longoria lux takes off
for the plate the ball is flipped to
buster posey and he tags out
gavin lux
and the faces are loaded for mookie beds
here's the 0-1
fly ball left field well hit drifting on
back is bryant he'll make the catch a
step in front of the warning track
tagging and scoring is bellinger on the
sacrifice fly by mookie pence and the
dodgers have a 5-1 lead now corey seeger
so here's seeger one for three in the
game left-handed hitter and he belts one
in the right field
that goes yaz at the warning track makes
the catch
and the inning is over
that's not generally the way
rogers does it he doesn't generally walk
the first guy and then give up two long
fly balls
but he did get the final outs of the
inning the dodgers get another one evan
longoria coming up with two out
and bryant at second base the 0-1
ground ball to short right at seeger
easy play flips to first the inning is
over and easy inning for frateral
no runs one hit one left
after five and a half it's the dodgers
five and the giants won
bellinger's had two singles in this game
he's also grounded into a force play
he's two for three there they go the
pitch
hard ground ball knocked down by a rough
it ricochets over to le stella he picks
it up and throws to lintel covering it
first in time for the out
and the inning is over here is chris
bryant brian has had two singles and a
walk so he's been on base three straight
times
and he's had six hits and twelve at bats
in the series
two and two the count runner at third
and bryant slow roller out to third base
justin turner makes a play another run
is him
so that'll be an rbi ground out both of
the giants runs tonight coming on
groundouts
now will smith coming up
smith with a fly ball to center field
duggar going back way back and it is
gone a home run
smith a two-run shot
and the dodgers now lead it seven to two
there wasn't a whole lot of doubt about
that one
now donovan solano
0-1 solano pops it up
short right out goes trey turner
and he gives way to mookie betts who
makes the catch the dodgers win 7-2
setting up thursday night in san
francisco it will be a one-game season
between the dodgers and giants
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes